so look at let's look again in the
simple case when we got one variable One
X
again we're going to get a bit more
mathy now this is the form the
mathematical form of the gaussian
density function
for class K
when you've got a single X
so there's some constants over here
the important part that depends on X is
in this exponential form over here
and we see there's a mu sub K which is
the mean for the observations in class K
the population meaning Class K and sigma
sub K is the variance for that variable
in class K
now in the first instance we're going to
assume that the variance Sigma sub K is
actually the sigma the same in each of
the classes
now that's a convenience
it turns out it's an important
convenience and it's going to determine
whether the discriminant function that
we get the discriminant analysis gives
us linear functions or quadratic
functions
so
if we plug into Bayes formula
the formula we had and two slides back
we get a rather complicated expression
so we've just plugged in this the form
of the density in the numerator and
there's the sum over the classes in the
denominator
and it looks pretty nasty
well luckily there's some
simplifications and cancellations
um
now we get this because to classify an
observation to a class we don't need to
necessarily evaluate the probabilities
we just need to see which is the largest
so if we take logs whenever you see
exponentials the first thing you want to
do is take logs and if we discard terms
that do not depend on K
then we so that's amounts to doing a lot
of cancellation of things of
terms that don't count
this is equivalent to assigned into the
class with the largest discriminant
score
and so that complicated expression boils
down to a much simpler expression over
here
and notice it involves X
the single variable in this case and
then it involves the mean and variance
for the for the distribution and it
involves the prior
okay and importantly in this case this
is a linear function of X so there's a
single coefficient for x
there's a constant and then there's a
constant term which is consists of these
two pieces over here
okay
and so we get one of those functions for
each of the classes
if the two classes you can simplify even
further
um and let's suppose now that um the
probability of class 1 is equal to the
probability of Class 2 which is point
zero five
then you can see in this case that the
decision boundary is exactly at mu 1
plus mu 2 over 2. so
it's back to this picture
um
in the previous slide in this case the
price we equal these are actually two
gaussian distributions
and the decision boundary here is at
zero in this case the two means were
exactly the equal amount on the opposite
side of zero so the average is at zero
so intuitively that's that's the right
value for the decision boundary which is
the point at which we classify it to one
class the boundary at which we switch
from classifying to one class versus the
other
shows so see if you can show that you
basically use this expression for each
of the two classes and look to see when
when it's the ones bigger than the other
not that hard to do I'm confused there
was a square term in the previous
expression and it's gone oh Rob are you
causing trouble here again
I was hoping to avoid that nasty but
Rob's right what if if you expand out
this Square term here there's going to
be an x squared
but you know it's got there's an x
squared in the numerator and there's X
squareds in the each of the terms in the
denominator and there's no coefficients
in front of that x squared that's
specific to a class so that's one of the
things that cancel out in this ratio
Rob knew that
all right
so this is with populations what happens
if we have data we can't draw nice
density functions like we've done over
here but we just estimate them so here's
a picture where we've actually got data
so we've drawn histograms instead of
density functions
now what we do is we actually
we need to estimate the for the gaussian
rule we need to estimate the means in
the two populations and the common
standard deviation
well in this case the means
um
the true means are
minus 1.5 and and 1.5
which means the average mean is zero and
the the probabilities were 0.05
but we don't know these so we're going
to estimate them from the from the
observed data and then plug them into
the rule
so
this is how we estimate them the price
we need to estimate so that's just the
number in each class divided by the
total number that's obvious the means in
each class we just compute the sample
mean in each of the classes this is a
tricky little notation here this is
1 over n k that's the number in class K
and this is a sum over I such that y i
is equal to K so y i is recording the
class label so this will just sum those
X I's that are in class K and clearly
that's the right thing to do to get the
sample mean
the sigma squared is a little trickier
we assume in the the variance is the
same in each of the classes
and so this is a Formula it's called the
pooled variance estimate
so
we subtract from each x i the mean for
its class
so this is what we do if we were
Computing the variance in class K
but we sum all those squared differences
and we sum them over all the classes and
then divided by n minus k
so if if it doesn't make too too much
sense another way of writing that is is
in this form over here which says we
estimate
the sample variance separately in each
of the classes
and then we average them using this
formula over here
so this is just like a weight on each of
those variances which and that weights
to do with how many observations were in
that class
relative to the total number of
observations
and then the minus one and the minus K
that's a detailed and it's to do with
how many parameters we've estimated for
each of these estimates is one parameter
it's a mean
okay
so there we have it those are the
formulas you plug those back in you'll
now get estimated uh
decision boundary and instead of being
exactly zero it's in this case it's
slightly to the left of zero but pretty
close